[Música]
boris johnson representado como un
mujeriego feliz ante los micrófonos -
cuando se trata de aprender shakespeare
un grupo de teatro se interesó por la
juventud del primer ministro británico
realmente interpretó a ricardo tercero y
por lo que leímos resulta que nos
aprendió sus líneas pego sus líneas por
todo el escenario
creo que son un cierto tipo de persona
tendría la suficiente confianza para
hacer eso y lograr encantar al público
la obra boris tercero causó sensación en
el festival de edimburgo
[Música]
un personaje pintoresco que desentonaba
desde sus tiempos en la prestigiosa
universidad de oxford
boris johnson descubrió la política en
el bello al college donde actualmente
estudian estos jóvenes ingleses
el padre de una de ellas también estudió
aquí durante esa época
boris fue presidente del sindicato de
estudiantes de oxford cuando mi papá
estuvo ahí le pregunté a mi papá cómo
era me dijo que boris era un poco
extraño y excéntrico siempre intentado
hacer el centro de atención
harriott lanzó una petición para evitar
la visita de boris johnson a billion
porque es costumbre celebrar a los
antiguos alumnos que se volvieron
poderosos pero para ellos johnson empañó
la imagen de oxford la gente le dará
crédito por el break sit o lo culpara
por el break si cuyas consecuencias se
sentirán durante años
también se hablará durante mucho tiempo
de su mala gestión de la pandemia
la gota que rebasó el vaso fueron sus
fiestas privadas en downing street en
pleno confinamiento sus ministros se
rebelaron la opinión pública estaba
conmocionada tuvo que renunciar mi mamá
murió de kobe no nos permitieron verla
en el hospital ni organizar su funeral
johnson tenía fiestas mientras nos
decían que nos quedáramos en casa no
creo que los británicos lo olviden nunca
nos sentimos traicionados por las
revelaciones de las fiestas de downing
street es una vergüenza absoluta debería
estar avergonzado
a pesar de esto algunos conservadores se
sienten nostálgicos de boris desde el
anuncio de su partida a una hora de
oxford se encuentran hellion james una
ciudad próspera donde johnson tuvo su
primer mandato como diputado o el
hamilton como muchos otros siempre ha
apreciado el humor de su amigo boris
éramos un grupo recién salido del
colegio antes de ir a la universidad
recuerdo que boris nos dijo vamos al pop
buenos recuerdos en ese pop nosotros
pagamos la ronda así que espero que
vuelva pronto a pagar la lluvia quizás
podamos volver a hablar de las grandes
victorias
grandes victorias como aquella del 2019
cuando boris johnson llevó a su partido
a un triunfo en las elecciones
legislativas
prometió hacer realidad el break city e
incluso ganó varios bastiones de la
izquierda
conecto con la gente de aquí de todo el
país especialmente en las zonas del muro
rojo laborista ganando una impresionante
mayoría en el parlamento
el partido conservador llevaba 45 años
vacilando sobre el presente salida a
medias o total sabíamos que no sería
precedido
un break sheet que fue rechazado por la
mayoría de los escoceses
así que cuando los candidatos a suceder
a johnson van a perth la bienvenida no
es muy amistosa
a
el break si te cambió las cosas para
muchos escoceses como susana activista
en una asociación por europea
[Música]
muchos de nuestros miembros apoyan la
independencia y hay incluso más
partidarios ahora que el reino unido
salió de la unión europea nunca un
primer ministro hizo tanto por nuestra
lucha por la independencia de escocia
boris fue nuestro mejor reclutador a
muchos de estos activistas conservadores
apoyaron a boris johnson contra viento y
marea
hay muchos traidores en el partido que
lo apuñalaron por la espalda
independientemente de lo que se piense
de boris
es muy inteligente y un gran orador
no creo que son incomprendidos sabíamos
que era desorganizado y todo lo demás
tuvimos eso en cuenta cuando lo elegimos
la última vez
al día siguiente nos encontramos con
susana y michael un compañero de lucha
creciente costo de la vida les preocupa
la ira en escocia refleja la ira en
inglaterra
para muchos boris johnson fue más que un
individuo extremadamente destructivo y
deshonesto
la gente es cada vez más cínica con los
políticos
así que se involucran menos en la
política
y cuando eso ocurre los extremos hacen
lo que quieren
boris johnson sacudió el panorama
político el hombre del break si te lo ha
dicho ciertamente su última palabra sus
partidarios esperan su rápido regreso a
la primera plana johnson mantiene vivo
el misterio